we talked earlier about getting the
audience on your side so creating
empathy or sympathy I feel like I might
want to try this sort of you know maybe
when I go into the grocery store I'll
trip on purpose or I'll I'll do so not
follow of course but something to kind
of like Get me used to being in the
position of of wanting to feel stupid
about myself yes what you're proposing
is that you do something new and
unexpected break a rule it's a rule we
might say that you go into the grocery
store and you behave properly and you
don't trip and you're proposing to break
a norm maybe not a rule but a norm
a an exercise homework that I give to my
classes whenever they run more than one
day at the end of the first day I always
tell them between now and tomorrow
morning go out and do something you've
never done before it doesn't matter what
it is and it doesn't matter how you go
about deciding what to do the experience
of doing something you've never done
before carries so much creative value
and so much psychic value you that it's
worth having just for the sake of having
it and I illustrate this if you can
imagine
I'm trying to think of it here's here's
a great illustration uh
one of my students was divorced from her
husband and had been for a bunch of
years and they hadn't had a really
healthy dialogue since they divorced
and she took my homework as a
permission to do the following new thing
I'm going to have a civil conversation
with my ex and I'll call it homework so
that it's safe for us both and she
entered into that and had a really
productive experience and I asked her
later how did you feel and she said well
at first I was really afraid because I
didn't know what I was getting into and
and I didn't know if it was going to
work and then when I saw myself in the
moment and having a good experience I
felt really powerful like I'm I'm in
charge of this moment in a way I've
never been in charge before and then
coming out of the moment she said I just
felt High I'd had so much an
exhilarating experience of the new
that that in and of itself has value so
this exercise whether it's uh brushing
your teeth left-handed or talking to a
stranger on the subway or buying a
stranger drink in a bar talking to your
ex-husband or whatever else you choose
to do
there's so much
excitement and Discovery and humor
in Breaking the Rules and Breaking the
Norms so I predict if you take yourself
to the grocery store and stumble around
like a clown
at first you're going to feel scared
because all eyes will be on you and
you'll be the subject of examination
sure but then you'll feel empowered
because you realize I've got control of
this situation like a stand-up comic
owns the stage and owns the audience
you're owning that moment all eyes are
on you and you'll feel powerful and then
when it's over you'll just have this
sense of relief and exhilaration and
endorphins and adrenaline and all of
this stuff because I'm getting high just
thinking about it yeah let's go do it
well that's the thing that you said
you're really in control of the
situation so if I accidentally let's say
drop the basket and and the eggs fall
all over the ground then I'm
legitimately I'm going to feel stupid
about myself but if I not that I want to
do this and not waste product but do
something similar where I drop my
grocery bag of something and and it's
not a major thing but I'm in control of
it I did it on purpose I think it's it's
more of an empowering not only that but
if you do happen to drop the eggs
accidentally you can absolutely make a
Surefire joke out of it and absolutely
win the allegiance of everybody around
you by using a comic tool called telling
a lie to Comic effect stating the
opposite of what's true those eggs hit
the floor you cross your arms and you
say I meant to do that
and everybody's on your side and
everybody's laughing right because they
know that you're not suffering the
accident you just suffered you can
imagine sorry if I no please please you
can imagine I've been thinking about
this a lot I'm writing a new book it's
called The Book of practice the subtitle
is how to do better what you want to do
well and one of the things that I'm
looking at is this idea of
self-monitoring
I I try to be in a moment and also be
observing myself in the moment at the
same time and just checking in it real
in real time am I doing what I want to
be doing now
I'm checking in with my hands and
reminding myself let's get those hands
under control and don't let them fly
around all over the all over the camera
I know you don't care but I'm
self-monitoring it's a goal that I have
to keep my hands still if I find myself
not achieving that goal if I'm actively
self-monitoring then I can course
correct in a moment if you think about
that moment in the in the
um
in the store where the eggs go down
if you're self-monitoring you realize
you have a choice you could take this
bad outcome and make it worse by
generating all kinds of bad energy
around it or you can take this bad
outcome and start to make it less bad by
generating positive energy around it and
that's a choice you have every moment
and that's an that's a choice you can
access as long as you're paying to
yourself paying attention to yourself in
the moments you're in
well is that part of being in the comic
Space is really dialing into who you are
you're in idiosyncrasies and how other
people see you
yes yes exactly there are a couple of
things to think about one is you have
strengths that will be your strengths
and knowing what those strengths are and
how to use them and leaning into them
further is is better for you
there are a lot of things that you just
can't do well
comically or creatively you can choose
to do the easy things you can choose to
get better at doing the hard things but
there is a relationship between what is
natural to you and what works well for
you and I can give you an example from a
kind of a different perspective as you
might know I'm something of a
self-described expert in poker that is
to say I've written 10 books on the
subject so I should know one or two
things about it and one of the things
that I know is poker players at a table
have an image and that image might be a
fear fearsome image a scary image Crazy
image innocent image stupid image
playful image a clueless image intense
image checked out image any of these
things
for Effectiveness in poker you need to
ask yourself what image can I project
that's in harmony with my nature in
other words how can I be more me so for
myself playing poker fearsome doesn't
work I can't scare people but playful
works great I can disarm them why
because I'm naturally not a fearsome
person but I Am Naturally a playful
person so that's an example of knowing
something that's true about myself first
knowing it second owning it like it's
okay for me to be playful and then third
using it as a tool so if I can boil all
of that down to a algorithm
know your strengths
own your strengths and use them as tools
so don't try to become you know let's
say in in World Wrestling they they all
had Dawn these these sort of not avatars
but these are these sort of monikers or
I don't even know I think Avatar is a
good character right Avatar yeah and who
knows if it's sort of a larger image of
themselves I don't really know these
wrestlers in person but but we come to
know oh that's kind of an evil one and
everyone's booing and and stuff and the
other ones look proud and funny so kind
of like donning that almost sure you're
gonna cast the heel according to who can
play the heel naturally and you have to
cast a hero according to who can play
the hero naturally this is something
connected to what I teach when I teach
stand-up comedy you have a comic filter
and your comic filter is just who you
are plus a ton of exaggeration
uh my comic filter is the world is my
circus everything that exists on this
planet is here from right Amusement my
rational mind knows that that's not true
but exaggerating that comic filter and
taking it on stage like thank you all
for being here tonight you really made
my experience what's your name Bob you
in particular I was hoping you would
come you can already see that I'm I'm
taking a natural playfulness and just
jacking it up and that's really if you
want comedy boiled down to simple terms
we've talked about some but here's
another one that works a treat comedy is
drama plus exaggeration if you just take
a dramatic moment and exaggerate it out
of all reality it will become comic if
you take a normal perspective I'm a kind
of a playful guy and exaggerated I'm all
playful all the time I'm like insanely
playful then it becomes comic it cannot
help but